all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibottas thai guy
travis fresh on that thursday evening
campfire
big time vibes in the building but
before we get into all of that good
stuff we gotta start off with the home
team ibartis the cheetah how we doing
sir doing good uh had family in town for
the fourth did a little home project as
you guys know i tend to be doing random
stuff around the house i hung up a
big shade sails
um yeah fair warning i know friction
makes heat it's a dumb thing to state
but if you're drilling into like a brick
with like a masonry bit with a drill
that thing heats up please don't touch
the drill bit because it will burn your
finger like you touched a skillet oh we
had an experience yeah
even like before i'm like i know that's
going to be kind of hot and it was just
that accident like it's just like
it's like you know lose a piece of a
finger so
no it was i mean that's just one of
those moments but yeah got that done got
to my wife's family came down hung out
with them for the weekend i mean it's
like 103 degrees down here so there's
not much we can do but we went to go see
top gun again
nice that movie is fantastic if you
haven't seen it please go see it it's
very good um i would go see it again now
still just that second half of that
movie it's just amazing and finished
stranger things season or
like a night or two ago
that's a lot of the 80s happening right
now yeah i know
but yeah stranger things season four man
they absolutely knocked that out of the
park i can't wait for that thing to
finish so i've been enjoying some
entertainment a little less gaming this
week uh i've been almost i think i've
got a couple chapters left in neon white
i'm trying to beat that thing that is
tons of fun still
no doubt what about you travis
i am doing well i am 60 hours in to
xenoblade chronicles 3.
i just i just finished chapter 3 of the
game how many chapters are there please
tell me there's like four at least well
the first game had 17 chapters so
you're gonna need to pick the pace up a
little bit otherwise you're gonna be at
about 400 hours of play time yeah my
review is uh is due on july 26th i think
that's the embargo date so that means
i've got to be done by like the 22nd
yeah it's going to be
tight boys and you know no matter how
much time you put into this it's still
not going to be good enough
i know
no matter what people are still going to
call me casual in the comments can't
wait
um yeah so
yeah i'm good i'm i'm i'm doing previews
reviews i've got a i don't know if you
guys remember that game
roller drum you guys remember that game
the yes
it looks like stable it looked like
sable yeah it kind of had that that
weird art style it was personal
rollerblades with two pistols shooting
things
i'm previewing that again
and see
i'm playing that game uh next week so
that's pretty cool also i want to give a
shout out to my bros in the comments
right now buddha and ducky
he rolled with me in duality multiple
times i've heard the stories and i got
the sword this week yes
i got my exhaust
catalyst yeah so shout out to those guys
yeah been playing some destiny been
playing other games but yeah i'm pretty
much deep in the the anime land of
xenoblade and probably will be there for
the next three weeks at least so nice
hilarious what about you cog what are
you been up to sir
back from vacay i was out in the shower
so shout out to everybody who pulled up
man you gotta be so glad you are back
too i know yeah and yeah oh yeah that
the last day was not not fun obviously
because of uh of events you know what i
mean and shootings and and all type of
craziness
it's terrible you know and it had to
happen on fourth of july so i didn't
want that to take my energy you know
what i mean but luckily you know they
apprehended who need to be apprehended
everybody the rest of the people is safe
but um prior to that my trip was
fantastic
um really got a chance to build with
some people ran out door pulled
down yeah the face reveal randa's
outside he was outside outside so that
was cool and of course my man's you know
what i'm saying midway monster he pulled
up did some uh chicago it was kind of
like one of those trips where normally
when i go on a trip it's always work
it's always oh it's a convention and
then you got to do game coverage and you
got to do stuff or interviews but this
was a trip for me and just to kind of
relax and one of the homies is his 50th
birthday so we had to salute the old man
you know what i'm saying and uh give him
give him his flowers
well we still got him but um yeah i had
a good time came back um i've been
reviewing as does falls it's up now i'll
shout the addict shout out to um aurora
wolf we're doing the the multiplayer
aspect it's a fun party game i think
it's gonna do fantastic
and um yeah other than that oh and i got
uh this little thing came in the mail
little thing came out
finally okay yeah i can't play something
that i like on it no no you cannot you
will get married yeah don't touch that
because if the fed's outside don't do it
do it
don't do budgie i don't want no smoke
i'm waiting for y'all to give me the
word
let me know it's okay but that's been
going on with me but enough of this we
got this amazing
guess wait
welcome to the last word episode number
205 happy bungee day everyone seven
seven is upon us developers are getting
wooden swords cosplay is on another
level and bungie foundation again
continues to do amazing work as we wrap
up the story beats of season of the
haunted with a hitting you in the feels
kind of ending you know we are going to
have an excellent chat tonight but
excellent ease isn't even the proper
word to do our guest tonight justice
it's been about 100 episodes since since
this man graced the campfire with his
presence and oh man
has he blown up since then the amount of
talent and skill that this man has
really shows you what happens with hard
work meets talent let's start with how
he starts his day by hyping up the rest
of the world with his morning
motivations if you watch one of these
and you aren't ready to conquer the
world you might need to check your pulse
then you know this man is out there
making sure all those parcels get to
where they need to go
to make sure he provides for his family
talk about a family man as well working
two jobs i can't imagine sleeping more
than just a couple of weeks a night
killing himself to provide
and give the best life he can to his son
that alone makes him a true legend but
then
when he turns on his pc does that quick
mic and lighting check and then hits
that button to go live it's over
the one and only hype man of twitch with
over 40 000 followers who know each time
they see that notification that they
gotta tune in
whenever it's hitting a sick headshot in
the middle of a freestyle rap which
alone is out of this world but then
keeping it real most importantly keeping
the positive vibes flowing strong even
in the face of so much negativity it's
always a good place to hang out
working with the companies like elgato
power gpu respawn and of course advanced
sushi and even bungie knows the right
name to call this man as they help
produce a legit music video for our
guest heroes are welcomed here at the
campfire and we are lucky to be graced
by one once again the one the only
maze
sir
put your damn hands together oh my god
man i'm all going to get my own claps in
real quick and get myself hyped up real
quick just let me help myself
yeah i can't i can't i can't do the i
can't do the freestyle like you can but
now that after that it's your turn
oh man man man
now
real quick i mean
if
yeah
yeah i'm in the building really on the
hype stuff even though i'm stopping i've
been dropping off some light stuff that
work is real good i'm really on my
enemies i see all of my enemies
i need my energy crazy i gotta love it
i'm climbing on the starts never drop
until the floor always climbing to the
top gotta show what it'd be like really
gotta take me i've been trying to hit
some business so you really gotta rape
me how you doing are you awake yet let
me hype you up and trying to show some
love in this game and got me niced up
i'm all about loving this thing i'm
giving let's everybody need some love in
this game i'm giving back okay
since that definition make it i'm all
the last word ain't no way you can take
it i'm all about this love so i'm just
really trying to give it big shout outs
to everybody at the podcast the feelings
oh
with that we would like to conclude the
podcast yeah i mean i don't think we can
really top that so that's pretty much
all we got
yo salute bro like i just love how you
put it down how you give it up for the
community always a positive vibe let's
get right into it man first how you been
i mean since like he said like since
last time you've been here
your trajectory brother i mean it's been
outstanding and then to see not only
that to see the community get behind you
to see bungie get behind you to see the
commercial of it out there shining bro
like is has it hit you yet what's
happening to a maze
uh be honest not yet um i've been uh
uh it's been amazing to uh see uh so
much
so much love so much love from the
community you see how you have that
still have that balance of the the hate
side but you have that that balance of
what side is speaking more that that
powerful the positivity over the hate um
being as busy as i've been lately uh
that
it was an honor uh i'd say it was an
honor privilege uh during that time to
get you know get that notice of
y'all want me to do what type do it
and uh
be able to write those things man so
much going on man uh for my dad passing
from cancer uh
doing that then that time getting that
notice he got to see that
that we we got that kind of notice
before everything um but i i i um
a lot has uh
during that point man was was a very
busy time for me also i didn't have the
time to acknowledge what had i had been
doing but i've been very very focused on
being thankful for the things that i am
doing if that makes sense and it's and
it's in a sense where
a lot of people are really starting to
wake up versus what they used to see
hearing from everybody else by actually
getting to see the story there's so many
people that judge that book by the cover
to ever open the book and read the story
you know what i mean and i think that in
a in a sense that a lot of people are
finally starting to open that book
and read that story because they okay
wow this is real
and you you know what's real when you
got the entire you got a lot of people
at bungie that really love what i do you
got a lot of them there that love the
energy love what i provide for their
their community my community it's
it's what they want for their game it's
what they want
for their vibe their change what they
want they want that peace they want that
love they want people to be able to feel
that they can play this game and enjoy
it as much as i enjoy it
and uh
i think in a sense uh i still haven't uh
took that time to uh just sit back and
and and feel that grace that love
because
it's not over it's just only the
beginning you get what i'm saying so
it's that and once that engine starts
rolling for me i've got to keep on going
as a as a promise that i've made my
father who has given me so much energy
man over the past couple of months uh
it it is definitely big to stay focused
uh take care of my son and make sure
that he's doing well and take care of my
community make sure that they're
elevated and motivated and just try to
keep the world at bay or what we're
hanging on by this beautiful like this
this this i won't even call it a
beautiful thread call it a very tight
thread and try to push this this this
positive this motivation and this energy
as much as i possibly can while i'm at
the table you know what i mean so i want
to make sure that i can be at this table
and i feel like since that video has
come out
i have been able to
open doors for so many others oh
absolutely that that felt like that this
is not like this can't be real but i
made these things possible yes what i'm
talking about you know what i mean so
it's like oh i know i i opened this door
to a lot of other people said now i
believe now i truly believe i know this
guy i now truly believe that this could
possibly be a thing and dreams can be
possible really just got to put that
time in man and knowing that there's
like hey you should be feeling good man
your celebrity here no i don't feel good
i'm not done yet i got things i got to
do you know what i mean this is just
only the beginning i just managed to
open the door now i got to get up in
there you know what i mean so it's more
likely i just i got to keep this path
rolling try to keep everybody at bay
here and and let them know that dreams
are very very much possible because it's
only like i said it's on the beginning
and
it's just so much more man but i am i
can't say uh today that as i actually
take the time that y'all are very very
much noticed me with so much of this uh
love that y'all have uh showed me that i
have definitely took notice of uh how
many uh smiles i've managed to put on so
many people's faces oh no doubt no doubt
brother well said well said your journey
is just beginning again i thank e all
the time for um
actually having me cross paths with your
content and again to see what's going on
and in my mind when i saw it it's kind
of what you said which is pretty much
like it's inspiration obviously you know
brothers like us you know we we don't
see it a lot and
it's good to see you know the
representation but as well just you
being yourself right that's the people
understand that correct you could be
yourself and still and still win and
that's beautiful i got more to say but i
don't want to dominate the town cause
we got the homies with me i don't want
to interrupt this this is amazing
it's just beautiful mine if you don't
mind if i get get in on that with you as
well lord i i think me and you have that
that solid connection of understanding
of how hard it is to come from to do
something like that in a space that's so
filled in the space being so tight at
that and being able to open that door
and be recognized by a company by the
name of bungie yeah over drawing
something that that that that's that's
a level that so many people want so many
people want that kind of level but at
the end of the day i think it's just a
very much of a very strong shock of that
that this guy is really what he's saying
is that they say he's live in the world
yes positivity just can't exist so it's
not allowed and i'm that type of person
that says hey hey hey we what we now
gonna do is say what is not allowed hey
i'm a positive individual you're not
gonna tell me i can't announce that i'm
a positive individual and i put so much
positive love into the space each and
every day you know i mean that's
something you cannot take from me i use
every social media platform to be able
to do that and we just it's it's been
it's been so
negative lately man or these these these
these years that we've been in it's just
been very very negative and it's only
going down and ain't going up so we're
trying to do what we can in the space to
provide at least a little bit of that
good energy man for a lot of people that
can still use it because in this world
right now man it's just it's like what's
happening what's happening you know no
absolutely absolutely last point i'll
say and it's just that um like what your
shirt says and basically what you
reiterated is what i like about it is it
shows that brothers don't have to tear
each other down to tear others down to
to try to succeed you could still have a
positive vibe bring people together and
that can win and that's what i like
about it you don't say it
people think it got to be something else
and i love it man salute to your success
i know we're going to talk about this
game and all the things going on but uh
you know a trap man what question you
got for me he's been a minute since he's
been here
travis
i'll let you go firsty oh yeah you
usually do the opening salvo where you
ask about his childhood
well i mean we've had we had him like a
hundred episodes ago so we got a little
history that's right he's been gaming
for a while but um that's what i was
like if you got anything you want to
know about phil okay i got something i
got something let's go what's your
loadout looking like these days in pvp
i'll load up look
let's get right here
i want to hit y for inspect right now
let me inspect it right
um the loadout i've been using these
days is uh i'm uh became
uh what everybody has known me in the
community for now is the glade king uh i
use a lot of the glaive aspect of the
game some of the things a lot of people
didn't really truly much enjoy or felt
useful i took advantage of that uh glade
when it came i won which queen drop um
took a little bit to uh learn it a
little bit but i feel like i've mastered
the core of it i beat it use it with
grand masters i beat it uh solo did the
solo duality with the glaive uh big
shouts out to uh
uh mr hulk himself uh
he i took his glaive and i sort of use
that solar style and uh but i've been
very very more towards my love my enigma
i think it's at 550 level now i've been
using this thing for a very long time
um
yeah it's that that thing has about 55
000 55 56 000 kills i can't remember uh
it's got a lot of bodies on it um but
i've been using that thing to clean that
thing off
to uh
to push so many things that a lot of
people don't believe that glaives can do
uh bringing bungee bringing glaives into
a space a little bit of change of pace
and a little bit of a different type of
weapon was something i've always wanted
to uh damper into because i've always
been the type of person to use the hand
cannon shotgun loadout or the hand
cannon sniper loadout and now now these
days i'm using that veggie wing oh
yeah frost balls got a video up man we
played uh last week
i saw that clutch snipe i saw that yeah
yeah so i've been using uh we're back
with the vigi wing the beloved and just
having some fun so my loadouts have been
post sniper glaive uh hands down uh
that's what i've been dipping diving
into loadouts these days
oh i like that i like that okay i could
dig that e
yeah i kind of wanted to ask you
because i mean you are the man of the
positive vibes but
it's been 100 episodes since we had you
on few things have happened since then
so where is
in the past say you know couple of years
basically
from where destiny was then to where it
is now where do you find the state of
destiny 2 when you go in to log in and
play where is the state of things
obviously you're having fun in pvp how's
pve how's the story where is the state
of this game to you right now
the state of the game to me right now to
be in a very honest aspect it is it is
definitely it's just there um i put it
in it's there um if you have not had a
chance to use weapons or
taking a chance to get better at
something with the weapon this would be
the perfect time if you have never had a
chance to go make friends this would be
the perfect time while the game is at
this this standpoint
this would be the perfect time to make
those those changes take a glance and
take a chance with other weapons do
something that you've never done in
destiny before go chase some lore knock
out a triumph do something that you've
never done go and test something solo
something
take that time and put it to use um the
story by far amazing bungie has really
stepped up when it comes to the story
part of the game i've been enjoying
every bit of the story i would turn my
music off just listen to how serious
this story is
exactly it's it's
i like it i love the story uh pvp
pvp is
i will call pvp pvp
it's always been the same thing for pvp
adapting the metals metals have always
been there size besides something just
changing and something coming away from
the game um
it's exotics in the game that's been
there for such a long period of time for
pvp that if one gets nerfed there's a
new
meta of exotics that you're hoping to
get nerve because that's what what pvp
players who play do if something gets
nerfed there's something out there that
they find and they can get their hands
on and use and
get used to that and in the community go
complain about that and get that nerve
there's always going to be something in
the game no matter what it is it did it
didn't have the spotlight but when it's
something's nerfed that becomes light
and then that gets nerfed so it's an
ongoing fact of what pvp is i would say
something about the in air accuracy i
don't see too much about it now i
understand there's a lot of people
who've been playing pvp a whole lot more
i haven't been playing it a lot this
season i just started splurging into it
a little bit more um the end in air
accuracy could use a little bit of work
um i just i think there's just a lot of
people just used to that uh in their
accuracy taking those shots i do believe
that it can it could get uh you can dip
down a little bit into it to see what's
going on with it a little bit more but
uh besides that pvp is just it's the
same as it was before to me pvp still
pvp people still bagging still talking
trash still disrespecting each other
still playing the game you can see and
say you hate pvp but you'll be playing
it that's more likely the whole vibe and
whole mindset i got for pve
it's this is a vibe for me i tell people
about destiny any time and point ain't
nothing like it out there as a streamer
and an entertainer i can sit here and
play this game and talk to a chat and
chat just knows how to make things so
much better when it comes to pve i
didn't play so much of that nightmare
containment man that i got every weapon
done just talking to chat and not even
realizing how hard i was grinding yo
that's just that's just the whole vibe
yeah
exactly i'll give a chat
you got a chat i don't care if it's one
or two people you got a chat and they're
talking to you lord jesus you lose track
of time yeah i can talk about anything
speaking of talking to people um you had
a very famous segment that i wanted to
give you bars or this is before the
season two seasons before that uh you
you wanted to talk to marissa wanted to
holler at her you had things you wanted
to get off your chest and it was it was
very eloquent sir you just kicked as the
kids because you was kicking the vibes
to be solved and uh we want to know how
that how that whole thing took place sir
[Music]
man
yeah you you you have to do you have
things to say
i love morrow man jesus i've walked
it was it was an awoken
mesmerizing moment because my warlocks
aren't awoken so i've had it working
since day one so but it's just like
seeing this queen i'm just like
i'ma have to use the words chad shawty
you bet you know what i'm saying it is
just
you are here you got magic powers but
lord jesus have you seen mine you know
what i'm saying that's the mindset i
want to roll wrong with like
you've been messing with shax he missing
no horn
[Laughter]
stop messing with the news
i'm gonna show you how to nova war baby
[Music]
how do you think the horn got stepped
off
you know i love you lord i love you baby
yeah i love you but i'm gonna kick it
i'm gonna kick you to keep it real i had
to drop them bars yes i'm on it that's
nerd that's sir balls yes i loved it
listen it was it was pure fun and the
fact like the way you made it a thing it
was just classic moment i'll show people
who don't play destiny that was like yo
this kid is he's out of control he's
super talented the way you can just flip
it was amazing but uh yeah man
definitely definitely one of the
highlights i had to give you your
flowers on that one but uh
we got this game to talk about even
what's going on man we got to see
what we just saw
that's the the triumph score that only
amazes got access to yes because he got
that music video made and for that he
got a special emblem and
uh
yeah and teddy's now going to be mad if
he knows there's something out there
that he can't get
yes
[Music]
no we got to see the end of season of
the haunted yeah and
like i will definitely say i didn't
quite know what to expect and how it was
gonna wrap uh i think we got a little
piece of what a couple of us wanted
with regards to ties to the future kind
of cool moment um
as for the game play
i don't want to take too much so amaze
how was the season of the haunted story
how did it hit it did you like it was it
too long too short good vibes
always good vibes for you i know but
i i can tell you man that story this
this story for the season to hunt it
that was basically related to life
uh
seeing as different aspects of life in a
game called destiny brung into real life
jumping into the life of crow having a
bad turn of events arguing with the bad
side of himself
and being able to see
and come to terms with that bad side of
understanding and making change
and within himself to make things
correct
and having that bad person understand
his good side and end up becoming light
zavala having a struggle
of something he didn't share with the
world take that with life with some
things that a lot of people just don't
share with the world
and
that part right there
struggle being able to overcome
loss i brought his demise i could feel
i can feel zavala's story in real life
because i took his story and compared
that with my father
and how i felt on a level with him you
know what i mean some of the things i
wish i could share with him more this
that in the third
uh
and how
they came to terms
he became a stronger person that bond of
release and being able to work together
and jump into kaido
and kaido just being so being so tough i
always tell people so many people are
tough on on the uh
on the outside but in the inside is
where it hits you know what i mean you
could be strong physically but your
mental mindset the inside is where you
break you know what i mean and i think
uh
at a point with a
title that's why i got the most excited
you know what i mean that part of the
story was oh snap i don't want to break
it down for anybody out there near the
the closure is yeah closure is just
being able to fight alongside kaido
was the most hypest moment of my life
too short baby i'd say too short for me
you know what i'm saying too
short
story was just too short i need more
this was such a tease uh the story by
far
is is
bungie is ready to just
i'm always rooting for them they just
ready they ready to kick some ass i
don't know what they got playing but
they already kicked some ass
with this storytelling that they got
going on now man cause now i'm starting
to get into my feelings i'm starting to
understand these characters a little bit
more you're starting to talk a little
bit about their backstories and how they
just come together
how they come together
zavala and kaido oh well
they came together
wow careful
very touching
let everybody else catch him but just
being able to see those two
like understand each other so much
better
like
zavala and kaido would like
that they're like this now but you know
what i mean that's amazing
that's enough that's the hand what was
that again
that's sort of like morrow song if you
think about it because i did use this
there too
[Laughter]
all right
i got different expressions not gonna go
to the other side of the coin maybe by
expressions at least travis how did this
season wrap up for you
um
yeah i i was not super thrilled by it uh
obviously i i you know don't wanna
these stories connect with people
differently uh to me the you know the
the nice vignettes of each person's
story was okay it was it was a smaller
scale thing to me it was a little
uh sophomoric in parts you know just a
little bit of kind of uh
they were they were going through the
motions to get to week two to fix up
that story and put a bow on it real
quick uh and then i really didn't care
for the
way that they connected it to the
witness because it's the way that
they've connected it to the witness
slash the darkness for seven years of
destiny which is that when it's all said
and done they go oh well you know it was
all the darkness all along they were you
know that there's a bigger batter
villain behind the curtain that we're
not going to show you still after seven
years uh except for in that one cut
scene with the with the witch queen so
um i i'm still
i i think it's obvious now that the
season is the seasons are sort of
waiting games and we're kind of in
between two hells right there's one
where where uh it's it's all about the
big bad that we don't get to see and
we're kind of just like delaying the
game or which is what i would describe
this season as uh or it's a completely
unrelated story and it just feels
completely uh disconnected and so i i
don't know if there's a good solution uh
with these the with the smaller content
releases but um
i uh i also think that it's kind of
hilarious that
we didn't change anything there was no
our actions had no impact whatsoever in
fact eris goes like oh yeah well we
didn't sorry guys looks like we got
tricked and nothing actually mattered
and kallus got to do his stuff anyway oh
also it's going to take us a couple more
months of doing the same activity we got
to we got to clear out that
i think the maze has waved the white
flag amazingly i have killed all the
nightmares i'm going to kill i'm not
even alive man
at this point i don't know what it is
i'll be honest i don't know what else is
it for me to do i've done everything in
the game for the entire community
because i've got everything
in the nightmare containment ever i
i got bad news for you man you're not
done there's still so many nightmares
for you to kill
this is uh
man i'm sorry
i'm just saying eris you know she's got
this season of the spring cleaning for
you gotta clean out that leviathan you
gotta get that uh
you better waxed
it right
anyway i don't want to be like a
negative person i love destiny i you
know i'm glad that they're keeping the
content flowing i will say positive
notes
i'm actually glad that it wrapped up
quickly i don't want to be compelled to
do the activity every single week for a
full three months i would much rather
just be done in six or seven weeks and
then have like a little bit of a break
and now i can focus on pvp and the stuff
that i like to do
um you know i like that they connected
the story with the larger one even if it
wasn't a real connection i think it's
better than the other strategy of just
completely disconnecting it and telling
a story that doesn't matter at all um
and you know i'm glad that they're
focusing on characters that we now care
about and know a lot more everything
that amaze says is totally valid i'm
just you know i i want them to do a
little bit better and i you know just
certain little things you guys know me
i'm a nitpicker this is
if you wasn't being honest about that i
could tell you i agree with every bit of
your point you just explained in such a
great way and it's just like this is the
feelings that coming in with that entire
i couldn't agree with you more on a
whole lot of those things so that's
definitely understandable i'm totally
with you on that travis
where are you gonna fall between these
two
probably in the middle
you know we got we got a good balance
this one because it's like you know
where i know where baze tends to be i
know where travis tends to be and yeah
i'm always in the middle for you know
it's like this
the wrap-up
there was good parts about it and there
were things i didn't like so the good
part about it was it wasn't another
server mission right it was it was
completely different in that context
it's like okay
we're going to work with kaido and
i mean um addict has always talked about
i like when destiny
lets you fight alongside your companions
i always feel a togetherness you know
they started teasing it with the cabal
now kyle's i don't know we're going
we're going in there and we're going to
do what we got to do i do feel it was a
missed opportunity
for what you know what the little seance
team of zvala crow
title to all kind of come together i
didn't like the thing that little
annoyed me i picked i have a travis did
pick where he's like
oh i'm down oh it's growing oh i'm down
too you know if i'm down it's just so it
it alright okay we know it's just going
to be being kind of there okay got it
that was cool she had a little moment
she put up her little titan bubble go
ahead guardian get that all right cool
you know
we can only fight with npcs when they're
putting up bubbles for us
14 and al qaeda all they're just
when you know when we played that first
mission for destiny 2 vanilla i thought
it was so cool that we got to play
alongside npcs but if i would have known
at that time that that's the only thing
that they made npcs able to do in the
engine all they can do is they put up a
bubble and then kind of stand there the
engine told me you get one
yeah that's it
that's it
make sure that kaido rallied
here's my here's my proposal for title
super she she gets on like the horn
right she gets she calls in she calls it
a girl
right and they just
drop
but yeah like you know we do that and um
you know i i did like the little call
back for those i am a leviathan raid fan
i always loved the callous fight so it
was a little call back to going into the
little spiritual world with the face and
the things okay cool we killed a thing
and um yeah we had a little we had the
moment right we had a little moment with
kyle you know i liked her story i think
the best because i'm i'm such a i don't
know if i've said this like cabal is
kind of my favorite race alien race so
for me you know everything is very
lordly royal brackets this
the uniforms the gold goblets you know
everything you don't say callus get fat
from strength like everything about them
is lordly so i like that but i like that
you know that relationship with him and
her like you were supposed to be the
next you chosen the run with the
guardians and now i'm gonna go commune
with you know with the witness and
search for this greater power so
basically what i got out of it is all
this time he's been
tricking guardians and luring guardians
to try to come with him and he's about
to be the harbinger or whatever it is
for almost like a almost looking like a
rock not a replacement but he gonna be
in a similar kind of role so to me the
thing though was at the end because
what i felt with um especially this is
gonna sound weird i'm gonna connect it
but what disappointed me with beyond
light was when i saw the stranger
eris in the drifter right i thought we
were gonna get some real dark avengers
the unholy team that's willing to do
whatever they got to do
because we know the goody goods ain't
going to play with the darkness and they
ain't go you know like these three are
willing to break rules right somewhat
osiris sometimes but those three
definitely and i felt like drifting
wasn't really part of it you know what
i'm saying we got more of bray
eris has been great she's been like
everybody's therapist this year because
she's going to shout his fix your face i
got you
you know i said but i felt like what is
drifter really doing and we finally get
a little bit into the ground well
besides yeah but we finally i know where
drifters at this season where he is my
guardian's personal nightmare he's
sitting over me in his ghostly phantom
form going alright right come play
gambit and i'm like i don't want to i
can't i can't do it that's me but it's a
gorgeous
person
his name is just as what he say is the
drifter
he's doing his own thing right now like
we i feel like there's going to be more
on drifter very soon we don't know what
the drifter has been doing and bungie
has always been really really good with
like we'll get excited for so many
characters but we know we don't forget
about a certain character you know what
i mean
has always
been
exactly who he say is oh absolutely he's
gotta be out here doing something nuts
you know what i mean like it's
this guy you gotta be doing something
him in here if i'm all i'm thinking
about since you said that is that
dungeon with iris and in uh iris in
the drift oh in the prophecy yeah they
were going back and forth yeah yeah i i
feel a connection with those two man
somewhere man
to me even though it ended and i felt a
little unfulfilled i got more fulfilling
from that little recording
where eris is talking and we're like
okay who is she talking to yeah that
voicemail after you beat the mission
amaze you gotta run over there to the
side and there's a little joint and then
i'm like okay and then she says the rat
and i'm like oh
that's him so clearly they are commuting
on something and i want to know where
that go but to travis ultimate point
this the slight disappointment is that
we did all of that
and it meant absolutely nothing we did
the continuity
like you just delayed the inevitable
he's still coming like oh what what the
hell was the seance for yeah but i was
like i was like wait a minute
what
that
holiday this
is this is why i as i always say
personal growth is never worth it just
don't do it why grow confront your
personal demons
dude it's not gonna change anything
you know what i mean like come on
we learned a little bit
like season four of a tv show it's like
episode
eight where it's like okay what are we
doing all right we're gonna give you a
little more information about these
characters backstories what happened in
the current present time nothing that
happens next episode and that's kind of
what we got yes that's what it is
we are literally the netflix of destiny
right now like that's what it is we're
literally the netflix the next episode
exactly so when it brings up a sword of
destiny catch this and catch that we are
literally a live netflix on twitch and
youtube
it is it is no wonder that that bungie
wants to make destiny an anime because
i mean we've got 15 seasons of us just
powering up at this point right just ah
so i feel like we're overpowered now man
at this point i don't know what's going
on
new levels we passing goku but he was
only fighting with 15
i mean i'm going to be in the middle too
um and we talked about it in previous
weeks where the resolutions came really
fast like aldrin was like way low and
then all of a sudden like cool we're bud
sweet high five uh and then kyle similar
thing i like the dialogue between them
and i think that's where i'm you know
trying to see the highlights is
listening to the dialogue the way it's
delivered the voice acting in those
pieces in
each of these weeks has been really good
when gal is just breaking down kyle in
that first time and then you come back
and she's like um what up i'm still here
you're dead now let's like get on my
level so it's like when you see the back
and forth and she has balls for him not
to cut your shoes no no absolutely she's
like you got burped by the son she was
like you're playing fail you call
question me she was talking strong she
had that strong tough toe sorry he
continued
and it's those type of moments that i
really do enjoy for the story and i
think as travis said i'm glad it's not
too long and that's a point to where i
almost wish there was a way to
like they got to make it a reasonable
length four was you know everybody risen
was like that was
that was a little short and this is like
that six to seven which is probably
about what they're gonna fall on
consistently because i think last year
was typically like eight or nine which
felt
stretched a little thin i think it was
even longer than that wasn't wasn't
there some seasons that i was doing it
like for like 12 weeks i feel
like my actual story for the actual
story i feel like we've maxed out at
like probably
seven eight maybe nine i don't think we
ever went like 10 11 12 for the actual
story you're not saying like it feels
that way because they used to save the
final plot point for the final last week
and that they've just felt like it was
like months of waiting for the story to
write and that they've changed up too
where they do actually you know you get
the one through seven you're not waiting
for chapter seven two months later in
the mail i was like i appreciate that
they've connected these things we've
talked about this is not news
it's like
because it's coming from pony express it
takes too damn long to get there that's
the whole point yeah uh it'll just sound
old now anyway um but we also get those
moments where you see
zavala like have that connection with
sophie at the end and kind of see her
acceptance and then aldrin kind of come
through
but when you know
when you see kyle
say you know he's
you know alice her dad is officially now
gone he's truly given himself completely
to the witness she's like my dad's gone
i don't know what
what kallus is gonna be to the witness
now the harbinger of who knows what i
forget what the he had a title somewhere
and all this
he's gonna be that but she knows that
he's gone so i mean
and then you see zavala on the other
side have that connection and see just a
little bit of peace happen with safiyan
that he drops down to the knee and you
see those two
generals of their armies per se have
that moment that hits them very deep and
those are the ones where i'm like this
is where destiny is doing extremely well
is in the storytelling in the acting the
cinematics and just those voice moments
they don't have to have a lot of words
between the two of them they they need
very little between those two harbinger
of the second collapse thank you um that
was the chat yes yes so like you have
those type of words of like what is
callous the harbinger of the second
collapse and we're like late fall second
collapse
stuff's gonna hit the fan in you know
six to eight months or however long this
thing takes to get here but when it gets
here we know this is gonna be bad but
these moments you get in between
make you care about them more it's like
i just got done as i said watching
stranger things season four
that season hits like deep if you watch
it and if you've actually enjoyed it and
cared about the characters and building
them it was like
when that when the characters are built
up and you start to like him you get to
know them a little bit you understand a
little bit more and then if something
does happen in lightfall
they've made us care about these
characters now which is what some of
these are for and that's why it's you
know if something happens where kyle
does some sacrificial thing or how's
that zavala could sacrifice for title
with lightfall doing something with
callouts that's that moment where it's
going to hit harder because if we had
didn't have this moment yeah it's going
to hit because we have a
longer term relationship but now it's
going to be even more and i think
these
these seasons while
you know nightmare containment
there's a point where we all have seen
it you know way way too many times we
get it that's just the grind of death it
was at two it was at two times that i
mean it too many times okay
well it's like we know we have those but
it's like and not every season is going
to be big and small where are the
resources where is this shattered realm
was an amazing activity
but again i and that story was cool but
again we got a little less on nightmare
containment a little more on the sever
missions and the story so there always
seems to be this little give and take
going on and then we get if we get
another expansion like lightfall hits
even close to the way which queen did
the build-up i think is going to make it
worthwhile so i mean again does
nightmare containment get a little old
it's like are they a little
a little easy to wrap up sure but like
there are certain moments in these
missions where if you listen to the
dialogue catch the little stuff that
they say the one-liners here the moment
between zaval and kaidal i think those
are the ones that make these worth it
even if like you know i wish
i don't know how to solve the is it too
long is it too short do we do this all
together do we extend it out even far i
don't know those answers and that's
again for bungie to do but i think what
we do get there are moments that are
very very high when we do get them right
about this
this season is basically definitely
based upon more lore and dialogue here
versus more gameplay stuff to do yes
this season is definitely a
season of the lore is how i feel
it is uh
based upon are you getting to know these
these uh npcs that we have here
even the dungeons the same way like
correct like it's all just it's
big storytelling um that's one thing
since you've brought that up ivan says
that it's
literally i get on and it's nothing but
talk dialogue talk dialogue talk
dialogue nothing that has to go in and
go and chase no no no gameplay exotics
none of this no this rebel needs it's
literally
talk lore
this is definitely a season of life
it's funny you say that though
i love that man
spring cleaning
uh i i think uh
to your point like if they're going to
do a season that's all about
storytelling my one like wish is that
they would just
then move the needle in the story
because it just feels like you remember
how uh when we had um farnsworth on he
was talking about how they kind of get
their orders down from hey we want this
stuff to happen next season i feel like
a lot of times because it's the seasonal
model and it's a seasonal story that
they also get a list of things that
can't happen yet and it's sort of like
all just building an anticipation i just
wish that they would unlock a little bit
more of like things can happen you know
last season we got
uh salad and becoming brackish that's
like to me that's like meaningful change
in the in the distance
i just i hope they i wish they could do
more stuff like that because really what
happened this season
right like character that we already
knew was evil and working for the
witness came back was still working for
the witness continued to work for the
witness we didn't kill him and then some
characters that we already knew that
were conflicted maybe got some of their
stuff resolved but it was it just feels
like there's a little bit of wheel
spinning happening so i just get that i
wish they would be a little bit braver
with kind of
making things you're like let the
forward momentum actually kind of happen
a little bit each season let the
building happen don't do all of it 19.
like let a little bit of domino start
tipping you're like oh
a little farther and then 19's like it's
about to hit the ground going in right
now something i've always wondered is
why don't they use the seasons leading
up to the expansions to make us lose you
know what i mean because during the
season we always we're just about to say
that we defeat sabbath we do all this
stuff and i just wish that that they
would use the off time to just like have
us getting crushed under the weight of
this new enemy and they build up the
anticipation and the lore and kind of
our negative feelings for that and they
could they could just use that whole
year to make us hate savithune which i i
think they did better with with sabathun
than they're currently doing with the
witness um rather than just doing they
it seems like their model is they do it
just the season before and then the
season of the big expansion we defeat
them and it's over right and all that
build up is sort of wasted i have a
question i wish they would stop doing
that gonna go put on business hat now um
how do you
lose in a video game season
with gameplay how do you how do you lose
well we lost in
uh destiny 2 vanilla at the beginning
right but how do you have that last for
18 months however long we get to how do
you continually have us
losing more and more it's like are the
strikes that much harder do you die more
frequently i mean from a game play where
you're right i mean losing from the
gameplay perspective i mean from the
story perspective of like building up
the because right now it feels like
we're kind of on top and we're preparing
for this event to happen and we all know
what's going to happen the expansion's
going to come out we're going to get our
butt kicked on the first mission or two
and then by the end we'll be back in you
know sitting pretty presumably that's
what's been happening and again i hope
that they will
break that up and maybe we lose in
lightfall as the name would imply and
then we don't come back until the final
shape you know that would be great if
they do that but i'm just i've sort of
always wondered like why don't they use
that year before to have a sort of on
our back foot because if you think of
the arc of destiny 2 vanilla which had
us losing it was all about us rebuilding
and finally coming back triumphant that
could have been a year you could have
done a year of content where you're
slowly like kind of getting your ducks
and getting your powers back and avoid
3.0 almost seems like the perfect model
to do that you're like realizing your
true potential of your like light
sunglasses as you lead into lightfall
like all of it just seems so primed for
that so um you know i don't make video
games so to answer your question i have
no clue i'm just out here dreaming but i
just i just you know no but nobody likes
the brevity of a villain nobody likes to
just get to know the villain and then i
will get it 100 a good well-developed
villain
will make that story matter and hit that
much more depending on when things
happen so yeah villain needs to be part
of it because if it's uh you know
one-off then doesn't mean that much it's
not a villain
like in a sense man
that
destiny has come
by far especially from where we came
where it was like it by far is it don't
even make it any better covert has came
in so many distractions with gaming man
and things that we want and what we used
to expect uh what we want and what we
hope for
it's like
it's like a rebuilt and you can clearly
we can clearly see from the standpoint
from all the hiring posts and i'm just
definitely out here just snatching the
good folks and putting them in on lineup
i get
it's all i can really do is play the is
honestly just pay to play the waiting
game we know what destiny we want dustin
to be and i tell people if you ask them
for destiny one things we'll go get you
an xbox or a playstation 4 because the
game is still there you want to get that
nostalgia i'm not really looking too
much for nostalgia anymore like i used
to i'm looking for brand new things uh
destiny 2 is not destiny 1 destiny 2 was
a different game yeah and i think that
what what what uh
what i'm waiting on is is if bungie's
about to hit us hard then the witness
better be a total badass you don't know
witness better be
this this guy better be doing more
than bringing down
bringing down house you know what i mean
these these pyramids these ships this
this door that we've been talking about
for so
long
better be
i mean
they better be well i want to say
yo the witness yeah it's going on my on
my twitter feed today
this dude is the new joker you know what
i mean like it is this i want
but this this hype up and build up of
this evil villain the witness is
it gave you a glimpse see this this dude
looks badass like he
he looks badass like we don't know what
he has planned he's got all the he's got
every part of the area all of the orbit
right there in front of him oh it's just
i'm anxious to see like
what's going to happen here like i'm
hyped for this this is right now we're
in the moment where it's just like i'm a
chill this is the point that a lot of
people say i'm going to leave destiny
and when you see this bungie has that
crazy way with trailers of bringing
something oh you know
nobody's doing that
better
back into the game
let me see what happens
i've seen all that but now i just want
to jump into what both you were saying
um yeah i think
the way i look at it is like
you know they're in a tough spot because
i would obviously we as the guardians we
got plot armor like we we're going to
win like like we know that on some level
but the key is to me
why i liked kind of i'm luna what travis
said in reference to the season prior to
witch queen why it really hit because
obviously yes i'm an osiris fanboy but i
love that that whole masquerade that
that changed us being duped and and us
losing in that sense right so it's like
yo sabbath was one step ahead one step
ahead every time we do one step ahead
and that added a lot of tension you know
what i mean to it so i i don't want them
to to go have to kill a character every
single time or you know do something the
same way every single time but i do
agree in a sense that there was a part
during this mission when the the callus
fight is over
and kylo's kind of like hold it i'm like
oh she stabbed it did she have like a
faded wound and you know say there's a
there was a part of me checking to see
if something happened and i i do think
that the stakes
have to raise a little bit though we do
we do we know that the witness is coming
and hopefully lightfall exceeds
expectation and it's truly like the way
they alluding to maybe a second collapse
and we truly lose in that fashion and
now have to cope in another way and i
want to know if they're going to be bold
in that way so that's what i think they
got to do they still have to
make take some risks
have some more loss so that we don't
always feel safe you know we did it this
day i know technically yeah i know we
did lose technically but it just felt
like a storm it was a draw it wasn't a
loss
what did we actually lose we didn't lose
anything we didn't get yet right
we didn't gain anything either but we
didn't stop him from
the implications of that
could be nine months away and that's
kind of the part where it's
you know you you want a little you want
to know a little more of like what is
the gravity of what just happened we
don't know and that's really the problem
with this is like
for years we keep being told that the
guy that we're facing is the big bad
and then when it gets to the end it's
always no no no actually this was just a
minion of the darkness and thanos he's
he's somewhere else right and i'm
wondering is it you know is is the
witness finally thanos are we are we
doing the real fight or or you know
we're going to kill the witness in
lightfall and he's going to be like but
there was actually somebody even worse
and then you know what i mean like i i
just beca because sabbath dune was sort
of built up in the same way it was like
this is the one guys it's sabbath and it
it really wasn't right like sabbath was
loki
thanos is still out there somewhere else
it wasn't really a big
big uh deal after all so i just want i
want us to face the big thing and i i do
have still i need to know what we still
got people chilling like let's not
forget i don't know what you see
we still got shorty froze in the back
corner yeah i'm saying like
we can't even get a respect buddy yeah
hermes is still somewhere out there
chilling frozen so she ain't even dead i
just feel like in in a sense that that
that that we we we seen kids and we just
like blah blah but that i go over there
you go right there right now sure you
still froze you know what i mean like
it is still in a sense
disrespectful
you think about it like i'm gonna be
real with you just like
callus is is who's next that's what we
heard right we obviously know
that callus is is this man is
it seems like
bungie if you're about to bring it and
yeah
if you're about to bring it better bring
it like this better bring it like you
know what i mean i need to know because
i know we're not going to get to the
witness yet like it is obviously there
callous is our next next problem right
yeah he is there um
but i ain't sleeping on on frozen shorty
you know what i mean like i cannot sleep
on that shorty because
anybody i'm not sleeping on sabbath
i'm not sleeping on still out there yeah
exactly people out there yeah it's just
so many people down there
yeah we forgot about but i didn't forget
i didn't forget i just it just hit me in
the head that like while we were talking
i'm like yo y'all forgot that shoulder
still in the freezer oh yeah i mean like
yeah like she said a refrigerator bro
she said i got her hair and i'm like
dude bro i don't know what's going on so
it's just it's just like i'm excited i'm
excited because it's it's your mind
wondering so many things man like
why did you just come so many different
plays man they got so many different
plays to play with
my theory is that last year was us
building up our avengers team right we
made friends with the cabal and friends
with the fallen and we built up all of
our allies yeah i think this year is
going to be the way it's building
yeah right i'm going to be him building
up all the people we're fighting against
we got callous blah blah and uh if that
if that goes well and then in lightfall
we get our butts kicked as i assume we
will and then we have a year of just
like the return i that will be amazing i
just feel like i've been waiting for it
so long i'm a little tired of the side
villains you know what i mean like yeah
and i know we've got three more seasons
of it or whatever i'm just a little
exhausted by it i kind of know you're
getting it though you know you get it
dude if they if they don't my review of
lightfall is going to be devastating to
the destiny community because i'm i'm
going to be so upset if this isn't what
i hope it is
one more thing i gotta confess i i
really have to say it man in in and it's
in no sense in a different way but i'm
getting tired of the season method man
let's talk but it's hot
the season the season method is really
uh
i think it's getting old now i know a
lot of games follow the season method
but this is just basically the uh
the uh uh
where it's just like okay
uh it's like we are it's literally it's
literally netflix i'm not lying like
it's each season it's a season deal in a
video game from tv shows i'm just
i'm i'm ready for more i know they can
do more but i feel like they can
somebody it's got to be somebody's got
to step up and do it right like
it's it's basically a company just
waiting for a company to do it first and
then they go jump in right like
somebody's just
i
i
yeah i don't know man you got to be able
to
in my mind man you have to take a chance
you know what i mean i guess
okay okay
you okay what you want
i mean this guy is preaching to me this
is gospel how often have i been saying
this sort of stuff and this guy he yeah
i'm only i'm human uh at the end of the
day like i enjoy don't get me wrong i
enjoy the game and always will but for
sure the seasonal method is
is is losing more than gaining uh
in a sense then
and that's just for a lot of games that
i've been seeing because i'm a person on
social media like every day
almost all day and
every time i see the season method it's
ugh you know what i mean that's my mind
that is just we got a new season coming
i don't want to hear the word we got a
new season anymore yeah i mean we were
just talking about this a week ago
on the show
about about me wanting bungie to do
braver things and i i would say sadly
they got it they got to take that jump
but i i i'm hoping that they do because
it's in in a sense i know
they can do it like they can do it they
have that that they make that move that
that will be super huge for them
to go
what would you like to see from them are
you looking more for like a six month
bigger shot of content does the scene
doesn't even have to be six months just
an annual expansion is just a grand
scale
it's
in my mind
we don't
when you do a season
a person is not going to play the season
if they don't like it so you lose there
okay
like when you call it a season in my
mind you call it season i ask my brother
you wanna play this like what season is
he don't even know what seasons he's not
gonna play it there's too many seasons
versus just
sort of like dropping some good content
let it let it let just
marinate it's like you cooking that
content you putting that content in the
pot
and that's your content that big pot of
content and they can cook and work
around that content while the game is on
so like on fourth and going i way with
these nerfs and buffs it doesn't have to
be a a weekly change up it's just
basically
we're testing this out right now we can
fix this when they i feel like when they
get themselves that team that they need
they
they're going to do something different
you know what i mean like being able to
play because destiny is definitely going
in a different direction right a very
strong different direction but the
seasonal method is never
it's never the
i enjoyed it in the beginning okay we
all did this new experience for destiny
we did but
it is it is it is so 2020 2019 now i
mean like it is this
okay netflix i could not agree with you
more but unfortunately
unfortunately our bray our brave little
indie company that used to go against
the grain just sold itself to a large
corporation and i do not see them
changing themselves
i want to adapt but if they wanted to if
they wanted to go further
and they wanted to take that chance i
believe if they took the chance it would
blow up and be big for them uh
and i and i and i get that the season
method but it's just it's just when you
see the season it's the season thing for
my man seasons of the hunted it's the
season stuff you know what i mean like
it's just like the worst season or
anything
it's a season when i saw it was season
of the hunted all i can think about was
the moon
like
it's the moon
i didn't enjoy the moon too much as
everybody else did yeah i mean
we went back there
to the moon and i still don't enjoy the
moon as much as everybody else does you
know me like
it's there i'll be real it's there but
you asked me when the last time i've
been on the moon i'm gonna tell you some
orbits ago because i don't even remember
the last time i even stepped on the moon
and
you know what i mean
you asked me when the last time i've
been
we lost the hobbies no he's back come on
come back
at least you guys are still there so i
know it's not me for a change
hopefully we get a vase back he spit he
spits fit
xeno1121 i want to know what's up with
eris and the drifter maybe we see that
in the next couple of seasons because
there's so we already know where the
drifter's at over my guardian as a
phantom
terrorism the other one necromancer zale
would be nice to get some future
season missions with a mix of cabal and
fallen npcs as you were saying i would
see the npcs working together what would
be the reason for
outlying with them otherwise fallen
cabal ally tanks
oh dude that would be sick actually
fallen and cabal tanks like one just
giant vehicle army driving down would
actually be it's on a flight you know
what it's [ __ ]
amaze just sent me a photo uh
it looks like the person in charge of
the seasonal model at bungie is outside
of his house and just cut the wires
okay well let me ask you this while he's
working on coming back because he'll
probably drop and then come back
so here's a question because as he would
like to see and i think a lot of us okay
windows are probably going to be a
message
hey look at that quick transition cool
it works for me
um
i think trap this is windows a little
off there but that's okay okay um
no you're good
take something like star field
a big space up or something like mass
effect where you go through and you
experience
hours and hours of content and story
do you even think it's possible for
because we get the light light and dark
saga we have that going on we have light
fall we have
final shape
theoretically if light fall is either
callus or zebu or wrath or some
culmination to
grow into whatever's gonna happen with
um those you know kind of building the
bad avengers whatever and then maybe
final shape is our confrontation with
the witness
at some point they said the story may
continue i don't know if it'll be a
prequel if it's going to continue on
would you ever like to see a destiny
story that is a complete package
but on the other side it's like do you
ever think that they could
the business model of the amount of
money that you make off of one mass
effect versus the amount of money
business-wise that they make off of
content and seasons and all these other
things uh oh he said his power went out
today i went out shout out to a bad
school okay just came back yo they got
him they defense man the fed's got a
bungee fence
man he was just speaking his from his
heart y'all come on buddy
bungie you got to forgive him let it go
forgive him man you just disagree with
the bottle that's all that's just
do you think it's like you know the
18-month like i mean picture what a
world of warcraft expansion timing is
like it always feels like it's 18 months
to two years where they go
here's a new
like big massive chunk of content and
story you play through and then they'll
like add stuff a little bit
is that something like you guys would
like to see i'm just kind of curious i'm
truly wondering where you think if the
stories don't feel right they're getting
a little old they're getting a little
long in the tooth
you know say they did change things with
lightfall what would you like them to do
i just think that this game is going on
forever i hate to break it to y'all i
don't think this is going anywhere
that sounds like good news i'll be
honest
today didn't they say they're doing it
for at least another decade exactly i
had a job posting where they said
decades
people were like or what was it tassie
was like oh i'm gonna be passed on my
character i'm gonna my son's gonna
inherit my character in season 243 or
something i was like oh my god well it
is it's going man like this is what it
is they have
for better or worse they have cracked
the code to live service better than
anyone else and it's crack all right oh
yeah it's
as much as you know we may complain
about the
lethargic nature of season sometimes and
i was the first one and he got me got
the receipts on me
for being in the mazes camp right i was
very kicking and scratching why
are they doing this seasonal model i
don't like it give me the big chunk let
us blaze let us do what we got to do and
then you know once we finish okay fine
but
the problem is i think tk a couple other
people in the chat said it the revenue
and the engagement says otherwise the
revenue and engagement does not speak to
the hardcore and the thing is
you know i'm looking at it right now in
a season that we consider
let's be honest i don't want to say mid
from a quality narrative standpoint
because we know the narrative is strong
but from a content standpoint we let's
be honest the leviathan is not as
expansive as maybe we would have hoped
we don't get the full exp extension
extension of it we get blitz and bits
and pieces the costello and and the and
the containment let's be honest
glorified public event right you know
with some little reward layer
and i'm looking at again this is just
xbox but i'm looking at xbox most play
it's in the top 10 most played games
right now at a season that the hardcore
is like man this ain't it you know what
i mean so it's really not about us
anymore and this is kind of my theme
i've been talking to other gamers about
you know sometimes we have become the
grizzled old game
and
and they've passed the industry has
passed us by in the way they consume
content and this netflix model
for better or worse and i i definitely
feel y'all i definitely don't like
certain things about it i definitely
there's some aspects i do like that i
could play other games right and i can
finish it but this is working for them
this is working for and i don't see this
changing any bit i see them going with
the anime stuff i see that's why the
sony relationship i think works for them
they're going to do the the matter you
know game that we don't know what that
is i was hoping we get some information
i know we allure into the bungee stuff
the 77 stuff and now we hear about the
nettie's money what the net ease money's
going to do and guess what most likely
it's gonna be a mobile companion level
game or some type of destiny connection
game to keep us in what we existed and
playing
so i don't see the the most i can hope
now the only thing i will fight to the
toothed end and i know i get killed for
this but it's like man i would i would
like a a new doof start with a new you
know i i personally you know i would
love you know i doubt they might i might
not even get that based on how they move
and what they model right but i would
like a fresh start next generation only
here comes the vault spaces comes more
technical things from ninja's
perspective and then hopefully we get
that but we'll see
well i
i think you will get the new engine but
i think you are right about everything
else about that about the model working
about them not changing it too much and
uh i i think that's a shame
yeah and that and it's
it's a it's the gift and the curse it's
the gift
it's the curse because we've been there
like travis said when you were this
little
indie revel going against the grain
everybody thought you were dead
everybody thought you were out of there
but you managed to survive you were
self-made self-paid kind of a situation
right that is also the dream that they
sold us they were like we're
reformatting we're gonna do it guys
we're in this and then that lasted like
a year and then they were like never
mind and then it's like look you know
tests came through and the new model
came through you know and then people
work it and they like yay you know i
don't want to call any content i'm just
using his name as a joke so please no
disrespect but like yeah glad yeah
tassie yeah caccus you guys are mad but
look at this revenue
look at this engagement look at like
that's cool that all four of you are mad
but we we eating here this is a good
thing for us and i just didn't that's
what it is man we're just talking about
this came back with powers
i'm sorry yo bungie you know forgive my
man he's just speaking from his heart
you know what i'm saying
he just didn't like the expansion bomb
i'll just talk about that just how like
i think they're gonna stay with it and
just ultimately i think it just makes
them too much money and even though i
agree with you brother because i was
with you what he had to talk me he got
to one of the fiercest arguments ever on
on last like to this day
travis it was yeah it was it was bad we
i didn't want to talk to him i won't
look at him for a while
but it was it was real he was just like
yo you know
they they you may have to take a break
from the game right you may have to play
other things i was like i want to live
this is my game why they doing this tune
in next week seasonal god i was there
bro and then i realized the metrics the
numbers and how they're doing well with
a model that as the hardcore doesn't
suit me and i just had to accept that
that's just the new direction they're
going
yeah um yeah basically i had asked him
if you don't love what the seasons are
doing how would you like to see content
released instead of the seasonal model
so now that you're back amazed
what would you prefer what would you
like to see what do you think could work
do you think anything else could work
uh
um
just give us three months of the content
everything is out there but put it on a
security release you know what i mean
like it's a
it's a uh
uh nice little uh tease of a of a bungee
block right there you just see the
bungee like no no no type symbol but you
see it's there it's open you know what i
mean it'll be open at a certain time
like maybe like after everybody has
gotten where they want to be level wise
and they decide to open when they want
to open and they open it because it's
there versus people be trying to
and i know it's probably hardest things
in the world to do right now because
what everybody does in destiny anyway
most of the people who have nothing to
do is glitch their way into different
things and that wasn't destiny one like
you know
we knew that content was a destiny one
because somebody glitched their way
through like
you know there's
no man not you glitching in other
content you know i mean like it's just
it's
i just say i i feel like the destiny one
model worked uh even though it was a bit
of complaint to set in the third it
worked
it was there like when they released the
release but
the content in destiny one lasted for a
while we're not talking about gameplay
we're just talking about how the content
worked
how the how the the time frame of those
worked
i love that a time frame setting if you
remember back in d1 days how they had uh
froda and then you see the next scale
wolves and you see the next scale there
was something hype about that moment
right there because it was a time
schedule right there versus they didn't
tell you what you were expecting it was
just showing you that this is what's
coming you know what i mean i believe
that a lot of people nowadays want to
know what's coming and i feel like i
i don't mind bungie just teasing just
the the trailer and not letting us know
oh you're gonna mess with e yeah
i think what he's saying though like
what if the season wraps kind of as we
got now and then maybe next week they
literally just dropped the iconography
of
or even just a name season of the blank
and they give like a
very vague symbolism of what the season
could be about or even just like a
character involved and you're like oh
you can speculate but i don't need to
know that like by the way kate gets shot
next season don't tell me that i don't
want to know i think that that would
have been better to come off as a
surprise
to us because as the streamers and
entertainers out there and a lot of
people feed the news to the world it's
just like oh my god this is what
happened you know you get more people
wanting to get involved with this game
and didn't even know that that was
coming you know what i mean it's it's
now it's just
it's to a point when you know what's
coming
it's just like
okay i know what's happening you don't
you don't think that knowing what's
coming is the reason that the players
want to get back into it
i don't know
forsaken wouldn't have been as popular
as it was if people didn't hear what
kade's gonna die well i gotta i gotta
buy this this expansion so i gotta laugh
i can say i can say that that part was
there but i don't feel like they should
have gave too much of it you could just
show arcade
just the way they did it yeah okay you
could have had him in a perilous
situation like right right right
showcase shooting the enemies and just
show that ghost getting shot and stopped
there
after that after that shot goes off on a
ghost black it out
right understand like
didn't they basically do that they
didn't show them straight up get killed
they just heavily implied he's gonna die
yeah the damage you ain't gotta sort of
damage this getting done to him just let
him show him shooting shots you just
because bungie knows how to do that he
said that boom boom boom boom boom
matching the music with the gunshots let
him do the
the the the golden gun
and then his ghost just
getting cut out
okay okay
i don't know man i'm not a developer but
i think that would have been pretty
sweet you know i mean just like
wait wait kate was a badass and then
then i just said who goes is that who
ghost is that you're right people not
even see audrey yet just like exactly
like almost like who did it yeah okay
people keep the crowd wondering what's
happening because at the end of the day
that's what's going to yank me in more
i'm excited because now we're talking
about this off work we're talking about
this in discords with groups like who
shot him like you know to be like
and build up that anticipation from
entertainers and people who do put out
the news and just like oh man this is an
exciting moment type of deal like you
know what i mean and it brings i don't
know i feel like it will work up more of
a crowd in a sense for me with that and
another piece for me would be
don't even give the missions like that
like those those those don't give the
missions where banji is just giving out
of uh a bounty or don't give the season
pass the oh you don't like waking up to
an exotic in the mail you know man i'm
not feeling it like i'm not i'm not the
d1 it was never like that right i didn't
mind it i don't mind working for guns
and new exotics in the game um it's it's
a part of what grinding is giving out
free stuff just so people can enjoy it
it's just not the way yeah i mean i i
look at it i look at it and i sense that
when
it was more surprising when you drop the
mission that had the gun in it don't
give me the gun don't give me the gun
for free make me work for this gun
and let me go get that you know what i
mean like oh
they didn't give it to you for free
you had to spend 10 us dollars for that
gun sir
either way
it's still free of zero every season
passed do i mean like
how many packages did he have to deliver
for that ten dollars all right it was
not free this guy was out here how many
freestyle raps
i will say this because he actually kind
of got me thought process
like what i would like to see in
lightfall it's like you know i think
it's the same camp campaign group that
did witch queen i have high expectations
there
seasonal content you know there's
probably gonna be something tied in the
things that i would like to see at that
point outside of we expect a new
subclass which theoretically could be
coming
but
like we need a season pass needs needs a
rejuvenation the artifact needs reworked
the power leveling system is
at this point
i wasn't entirely sure if i could do
grand master this this week but why
should i be stopped
like those type of the whole power
leveling system at this point the tin
is
kind of a joke it's not really needed
too much the pinnacle grind is
kind of there but it just makes it a
little bit farther depending on how much
you got to do i mean yeah they bump it
up every time but it's like
depending on what the soft cap is or the
power leveling cap and stuff so power
leveling artifacts season pass those
things that have been
pretty static for
a few years now i would like to see
those re-done champions as well it's
like we got lucent hive we've talked
about this before champions have got to
get a rework and update a change in
mechanics or yanked out of the game or
something because
we've had them for years as well so it's
just kind of getting to the point where
some of the stuff that's been in the
game for a while
over the course of like when it gets to
a light fall size expansion one or two
of those hopefully is what i'm hoping
hey can i join in on that a little bit
let me ask again
i'd like to say a little bit more i'm
glad you uh said that uh what what i
really would truly want is
we
i don't want to go back and do the same
thing over and over again every season
uh pinnacle pinnacle wise
uh i missed what we had in d1 was fresh
vendors of fresh weapons uh doesn't
matter uh what
what weapon it what weapons they are
just give a different creation different
like a different value of weapons like
it was in d1 you remember that when it
was just when you go back each each time
shaq's had new weapons the paladin
because there was some guns before those
ones and
the other vendors the fresh vendors had
different guns not just a weapon you
could chase
but
it was different weapons in in that
vanguard like the vanguard had a new
scout had a new hand cannon a new sniper
a new
something you know what i mean i'm i'm
looking for more of that to come in even
if you wanted to keep the same things
i would just want different weapons for
those vendors yeah i mean i don't want
to chase
these same don't give it to just iron
banner and trials give it to everybody
yeah i mean give it to everybody get
like make it feel make that season feel
brand new you know what i mean because
you go in the season and it's yeah we're
chasing me the weapons and it's good to
have them and it's amazing i love it i
mean if i didn't i wouldn't be chasing
all of them right but it's it's
it's in a sense where
it's the in the eye of the beholder and
if i'm looking at it and i'm saying oh
this is new i just like seeing new
things you know what i mean
seeing the same tower for a couple of
seasons seeing the same thing seeing the
same same same same
is
is
juice just running out yeah i mean like
it is just it's running out i wanna i
wanna see i want to see so much more
because i know that bungie can do that i
want to see hey shoo give each ge give
one of them give them a glaive hey give
each one of them a different glee like
you know what i mean like it in a sense
that
i mean we are at that point now where we
have all the burns for the glaives now
right like just give each one of them a
glaive or something specific that it
does since we got those new perks
vanguard perks that works for glee give
them one for the pvp glaive you have one
for the pvp glade from drifter you know
what i mean just it's it's those type of
things to me that speak like oh oh
drifter got a glade oh i don't even play
gambit but guess what i'm gonna get in
there
exactly you know what i mean get me in
for a reason to go play these rewards
you're going down yeah now you're
preaching to me on other things yeah
i've been saying that yeah yeah
just just just get me just get me going
you know what i mean because i'm like i
said i'm gonna play dustin regardless
because i love the game i love the
company i love what it's saying for this
is my favorite game there's no game out
there like it regardless of what we try
to prepare it to the gun play all of
that just feels really good to us you
know what i mean it's it's a game that's
really really embraced
so much of that that gun play skill that
everybody is now comparing destiny to
every it's amazing that destiny still
stands compared to every other game here
but it's i just want to see i don't know
man different things like
we new season
same thing
yeah i mean it's just
after the season's beat it's the same
thing
i was gonna say it's like that's where
that's where again that's the other
piece i guess i would say that needs
some rework is what is up with the other
the basic if you want us to live in
these playlists 50 of a season
literally half of the year we're gonna
be in these basic things once we do the
stuff that you're gonna do i can't even
go go replay the final mission because
it's done but they want me to play
strikes for seven years straight
and again as you said cog i know it's
like you're you're dying to it's like
the rewards behind these strikes like
strike exclusives and it's they're
they're like they're making baby steps
and we want them to make like triple
jumps
because they put a baby step in hey the
more that you grind out this playlist
and reset the reputation
now you can get double perks in some of
the columns you're like okay
on like my 50th riptide fusion rifle
that i've got from crucible or whatever
it's like i've seen about 600 of these
by the time my reputation's good i've
already got two that i probably want to
experiment with anyway one extra perk in
a column after i reset this thing twice
doesn't really feel like the juice that
i put in is worth the squeeze and that's
that isolated in pvp like it was in d1
give us a reason to go ground forward uh
versus the dungeon put the dungeon with
different weapons uh just sort of like
the new dungeon all the weapons look
different in this new dungeon you know
what i mean uh don't put the old weapons
in the dungeon with those weapons in the
pvp
in the oh you mean the core players
they want us to grind every day to
actually make it exciting i feel like i
just feel like if i'm gonna get a drop
of ice and luna
but also a drop of a matador or a party
crasher or you know what i'm saying just
like i know i can't go and do i can't
get these weapons anywhere else besides
pvp right you know what i'm saying and
if i want to go get this nice let's say
i'm just making up a word of a gun or
just talking about a gun that looks like
let's say the last curse it's a
legendary
now can drop
some crazy rose to it but you need to
play pve it's a farm i need to get it
here it's cursed but there's also
another weapon
oh
i was saying that putting some of those
weapons into play
that can really make those things like
you don't do do like make it make it
happen you know what i mean i got an
idea i i like where your heads out of
mace here's my proposal
uh put icebreaker back in destiny no
you you have to stop that now anything
that makes bullets you have to win 1
million gambit matches okay travis i
think you might have been uh thinking a
little too hard here trevor
look if you want to increase those
player numbers
you gotta you gotta make them work for
it man there you go guaranteed drop one
million matches of gambit who likes it
he's for it jesus is just going off in
chat he's got an eververse title he's
got an uh he's got ten percent damaging
crucible for ten dollars per match up
charges this guy just turned into
everversion he's another adventure maybe
he's coming that moneygram they're
coming for it
just saying guys hey bungie if you're if
you need a guy in marketing
i will make you i will monetize this
game it'll be toxic
you only have 10 players when i'm done
but they'll all be whales they'll all
they'll be the only 10 players you need
bungie
somebody actually brought up um
out writers in chat
and outriders world slayer that we
talked about this previously is like
it's a cool expansion but what i will
say about the rep repetitive nature of
trials of target guitar if you haven't
played it it's you know it's basically
not exactly a roguelike you're just
going to go through different rooms and
get different rewards as you play
through but
that's the point where the repetition
almost might be too much of the same but
the rewards that you get from that and
how that game is like excels so well
when you finally build a legendary set
and get all the mods crafted on a build
and the weapons and everything you feel
100 different
than you did with a completely different
build when you finally grind there now
is the grind too long to probably find a
legendary sat in that game probably uh
you're going to be putting in a whole
lot of time but the rewards you do get
finally when you build three pieces of
legendary armor you get all the right
mods on there you got two other pieces
that are now apocalypse gear and then
now you got apocalypse weapons you're
like okay this feels massively different
i can do so much crazy stuff now and
that's the point to where the the effort
that you put in
gets you something eventually it's like
you get another pulse rifle you get
another thing and i know you talk about
power creep now
and that's the point where outriders is
like yeah it's pve only it's absolutely
crazy it's kind of fun and cool but
that's kind of the idea of like i'm
gonna put that much repetition into
something
at some point those
the builds are
like really really cool and it's like a
balance between you could never take
destiny that far but again destiny
doesn't quite go far enough either at
this point yeah we're just like kind of
with new rad and we've always alluded to
with the outright is compassionate we
want to feel powerful and this goes back
to your whole
you know is it worth it with the 10
level grind because like the new season
come out you get to the 10 level grind
but like let's be honest we don't really
feel like we're dominating that raid and
dominating that dungeon for for the
effort that we put to grind the light
level right those guys should feel like
hey i'm i'm rolling with a maze he put
in the work he grinded so he could carry
you don't say and i think they a part of
it's part that part they've taken away
hero moments a lot i know
um you know that was a big allure to d1
i know even though i've had my issues
with crota but i do understand your
mindset e with like you know having that
hunter be able to you know saved the day
with the party or you know what i'm
saying or whatever and
you you miss that and i think the way
the scaling is
it's really
you really the only time you can break
it is when like you find this really
crazy build with with either mods or you
know obviously i got to give solar 3.0
some credit there are builds that we're
seeing that are powerful but
i do feel if you get to that light level
and these guys are my clan that are
killing shout out the buddha shout out
to ducky in this sinister that's in
there right now these guys are killing
it they should be the elite guardians of
the clan and if i'm rock with them right
it should feel like a difference as
opposed to someone rocking at my same
light level or lower and i don't feel
they reward the person who puts the
investment in enough to feel dominant
right
that's what outriders does well i i have
to give you that like it does that
really well why for me the power level
seems the longer this goes on it was 10
it was 50 now it's 10 again
why is it anything at all i know people
like to see the number go up but
if you sit there and you end the season
you're like cool i got to this power
level stripped away as soon as you get
to that new season and then you have to
put this exact same effort in through
pinnacles which over the course of a
season they don't change very much just
to be able to get back into a gm you
just could do the day before the season
ended and that's like absolutely right
like i want to do gm's on day one why
can't you
yeah no you're actually crap you want
contest power anyway see your power
there like who'd you said like ducky and
whoever else they could be 1600 power
level right now
doesn't do them a damn bit of good and
that's i think where the whole power
level grind the hardest content doesn't
matter
yeah you can technically over level
master nightfalls but when you get to a
point that doesn't really seem necessary
and then grand masters they want them to
be a challenge okay pick the challenge
pick they could be 15 20 for all we care
and they could make you 1500 and it's
still gonna feel that whatever they want
you to feel like it's going to be the
same way 1601 yeah exactly so he's
actually 1600 power level because he's
season past probably 500 or something
insane but that's a lot of time and
that's the problem that time doesn't
justify you to feel any stronger it just
doesn't he actually is almost 500 uh
sees your passion ducky is a beast in
the plan shout out to ducky shout out to
bulldogs
go touch grass please what is it
ducky
his body actually um recently became
merged with the couch he sits on
so
they're
getting a little becky
actually not about it the five of cards
whatever that
will remember that yeah you could pick
how much level you wanted to play
against and you could boost up your
score and stuff like that like yeah yeah
you should definitely bring back another
currency it's something destiny tuesday
no it's not a currency it was just like
instead of a currency like make it a
point where you hey i'm going to choose
a nightfall go in and pick like hey what
power level do you want to fight this
thing at the heart of the power level
you know the better you score then you
could have scored leaderboards oh my god
those could be a thing like there's a
whole cha and again this is a whole lot
easier not being a developer but still
that's the
crass is a myth yeah um
that's the idea here though is like
the power level grind in a expansion
felt cool i really really enjoyed witch
queen but when it's the 10 power levels
of just doing the pinnacles that you
just did last season again and again and
again until we get to the expansion the
power level in seasons just doesn't feel
right
it feels like it's just a tedious waste
of my time
when an expansion feels really good the
seasons feel kind of the opposite in the
power level especially and the last one
i made before he um
he obeys had cut was that he had alluded
to the shift that he see that he wasn't
happy with and i think there's a lot of
truth to what he's saying which is
that i think they've made a conscious
shift to say okay we are going to go
heavy narrative based
as opposed to giving them true content
change during the season and then the
expansion is where we actually attempt
to make
most noticeable changes to the game and
that's the part i agree i don't know how
i feel about that you know so i'm not
saying they're not doing anything and
they're lazy i'm not doing that shout
out to bungie you know they they putting
in work and they're working hard but i
do feel it's very incremental
during the seasons what we see to the
core gameplay loop as opposed to what
you get from the expansion and how i
think how we've david basket well it's
yo narrative team investment we gonna
give you this ball man story tune in
next next week in a netflix style
episode and we good we like it but we
still got to get that balance and still
challenge them to say okay but what's up
with these maps in pvp what's up with
gambit at its core not really changing
what's up with these power levels and
and still get that i hope that the
infusion of cash and i hope that
hopefully they're not diverted
with
other things because they are splitting
themselves now you know we got matter we
got a mobile game
we got a movie you know we got to see
you know and we have to hold their feet
to the fire to make sure don't give
travis one bit of that rope he's gonna
take it off i'm always gonna be
objective even if it doesn't suit my
narrative i do understand what travis is
coming from what i'm saying like yeah at
the end of the day we have to make sure
that the focus still remains on this you
know saying this what got you here
because if this goal
we don't know what's going to happen
and that's right that makes that makes
oof okay yeah i got you yep
okay
yeah because i get what you're saying
the game is what made all this happen
the game made all of these things
possible right and then uh
we just don't want i just don't want
like
i don't want anything to for destiny but
nothing but the goodness for it like at
the end of the day it's let's
it's definitely struggle it's struggle
right now at this point but most games
not even just destiny you can really see
what that says struggle man so much
going on in the world that is affecting
because at the end of the day we have to
remember that developers are also human
beings just like shows
i don't know what it is for developing
what they do but i know they take the
time and put that passion and i can say
that they they take their time oh yeah
we don't just as much time into
uh the video game is just as everybody
else wants it to be but man it's just
getting
rebuilding is the the hardest thing to
ever do you know i mean because we don't
know how far the the the tower fell oh
yeah just know
you know i mean like we just know i just
feel like the
i believe in i believe in what they're
gonna do i believe in the whole entire
deal i just think it's just strong
patience and seeing everything in the
world don't make it better like
everything in the world just don't make
it better just makes the frustrations
even higher uh
just i i i want i want to see the best i
really really do and i believe in it
after leaving after looking at all these
these like yet again looking at all
these posts
of hiring people around the world that
that this can definitely be possible
this is just telling y'all that bungie
is out here and they trying to really
build like this is just a rebuild a
restart
and you got new heads got people who
actually played the game that we knew
playing like that right there and
they're working now you know what i mean
like it's just you know it's just
it's it's just a restart we just have to
we have to be patient with it because
we're getting some of these things and
we just we like
what the hell is this
it's
let's give them the time that they ask
for because they ask for the time and i
think a lot of us have really forgotten
about the time that they literally they
dropped the whole story on what they're
doing and what they're trying to do for
us let's not forget the story that they
put out i say take your time
take whatever time you need take
whatever budget you need take whatever
pacing you need i will judge the end
product that's what i'm concerned with
absolutely
i appreciate that travis because that's
i think the one thing that i i know that
bungie loves is they love their feedback
or i mean no one wants to go online the
game is perfect
like the game is happy
they love your feedback too
they they love they love all feedback
they can handle these things you know
what i mean like they can really handle
these things and the mindset is just
it's just
how you bring it i tell you that's it
could be any development it's just how
you bring it
a lot of people a lot of people uh a lot
of people say they're ignoring us no
they're not if if i was making a video
game and you're talking out the side of
your ass then [ __ ] i'm gonna just go out
here and be that person and say that's
pissing you off but [ __ ] go ahead and
buff this real quick piss them off some
more it's more likely how you come at
something versus like what everybody
else is like you saw that on twitter
somewhere too
no like somebody was like you guys
better be happy i'm not over here making
the game cause he's like oh
oh you don't like laura lee splendor oh
that just got like six thousand times
stronger oh you don't like handheld
supernova yeah i just made that thing
push you off the map like right people
they could screw with you if they wanted
to they really can it's just like it's
it's a way to come at it man it really
is like you really just need to it's a
proper way to come at these things man
and and they want to hear that they want
that they need that kind of feedback as
well they don't we know we know that the
game ain't 100 perfect but there's
always a way to come
at these situations man a proper tone uh
if you see kids out here yelling you can
always tell who the kids are versus the
ones who have a mindset of a little bit
of sense to come at a situation where
we're saying well this
seems a little off and this needs to be
fixed this doesn't feel great not go
over this fix the [ __ ] bungie
they're not gonna fix the [ __ ] you know
what i mean are you coming at nobody
like that i don't think it has to be any
company out there in the world you sit
there and say fix the [ __ ] and then you
yelling at the thing you need to get out
of the game my brother and touch grass
that's what you need
your favorite levels is bad and where's
your lady where is everybody you know
what i mean like hello
i gotta come back
at a proper mental and i feel like when
a lot of people play trials at that
mental level is already at its end
at this all time thin level of anger and
i tell people if you're having a great
weekend destiny
i've already experienced trials for you
to stay out
yeah i i took all of the energy and all
that negativity i'm just telling you for
me stay out if you're enjoying your day
don't go and ruin your day by playing
trials and then taking that out to
everybody in the community because ain't
nobody got time for that [ __ ] like you
know you're like
being mad at the game that you are
playing of your own volition is kind of
crazy to me because you don't even have
to touch grass you could just do what i
do and touch other games
yeah
express that to the world that's like
you're just going through no place play
other games for a little bit i have a
similar policy with my girlfriend's mad
at me
hey
hey how you doing
that was that was too far it was too far
that was too far that that just got us
demonetized by your woman your woman
demonetized the whole video
the whole woman copyright claimed the
podcast
this
is very fitting this super chat's very
fitting i saw the last word has some
class in the top left hand corner this
evening which is a maze and travis just
proved that that's in full
this thing got demonetized this thing's
gonna get copyright i'm gonna get my
first copyright strike thanks to travis
over here
oh my god bro
all right he's got the he's the mpc and
he's got his two escorts he's fine so
lord jesus
girlfriend
what else uh
i mean that's
we covered a whole lot of different
stuff just kind of on the state of
things but i mean shout out to bungie
real quick uh for the twist
yes gotta cover that one um
number one the shreds of light cosplay
the stuff people like threw together
with stuff in their house is hilarious
uh go check some of those out because
they're actually pretty legit and well
done um
but the cosplay for savathune if you
guys have not seen this on twitter
um
the cosplay coming together for this is
just
it's incredible so please go check it
out it's the cosplay cosmodrome and
there's the savithun i think it's nearly
complete now wings and everything this
is
it's absolutely immaculate which is
crazy
uh also they've got the bungee
foundation going on um from july 7th to
july 20th they've got that
i'll be up there on the 8th by the way
the thing is the saturday and whatever
the night is that 9th of saturday yeah
i'll be there saturday uh doing
something for the kids man
i'm excited for that nice
solo solo
yeah so whether you're fundraising or
donating to
um they've got different emblems and
ghosts that you can get and all of
that's going to the bungee foundation
they also got a little behind the scenes
about the um the dog emote that actually
was for the charity fundraiser that was
the from the make-a-wish foundation
um he's got a rare genetic disorder spit
much of his childhood and he did
actually get a kidney transplant and as
a road to recovery he got a
kind of a support dog artemis and that's
where that one came from there's also
the little plushie it's about
you know looks like he's about a foot or
so about 12 inch and
he's in the bungee store bungee store
has some very cool stuff for the next
week in there if you guys haven't
checked that stuff out
the nerf gal horn is on pre-order yes
[Music]
don't give me don't give me flashbacks
with these nerf weapons
oh yo yeah
i don't need this trauma you don't need
that trauma nerf
legends and then they also had okay i
gotta ask cog did you ever do the
parasite quest
i still gotta do it dude
what a plus what hey oh
no no
it's like i'm avoiding it i don't know
why
the question is before you justify
cog
before you justify it i'm afraid this is
going to be your last show
um
too casual can be your campfire
uh the signs mr lord kai yeah i can help
you man i got no excuses
don't know why i did that messenger i
did everything that's not true you're
also not winning any crucible matches oh
lord jesus why are you calling me
yeah yeah
because
i'll watch you at some point we have to
do a last word crucible like one v one v
one tournament between these two
and we gotta see where we all stand so
we can finally see if this trash talk
actually matters
what if lord just comes out on top and
he don't even be playing then then he
can own it but it's like until then we
gotta kind of know if travis's trash
talk is all talk or not
lord i'm gonna need to go ahead and back
that up
have we not [ __ ] we played yeah we
played we played
was travis oh
god
how often do you play lloyd no i do play
the problem is
i'm gonna tell you what my problem is i
like mid maxing i like builds so i will
spend hours in there tweaking solar 3.0
going through missiles
not doing anything no i'm doing my
pinnacles it's tower times twelve
thousand hours
listen to you now now y'all being
disrespectful
you know what you've already got the
iron
how do i have a title that you don't
because it doesn't work
oh
okay
don't say there's no gameplay hours
if it was available for more than one
week so far it would have been done
i just got a little couple of gaps i
gotta feel what i saw there's a gap i
gotta think
it's just a gap you're coming for the
kids giving you a hard time cog
obviously
you're a casual um
what it is with this season i just got
to get that done that's the last thing i
just gotta get it done
i don't know how you decide to leave
that behind cause the woken queen over
there brother no i don't know why it is
because the the weapon itself not that i
heard bad things about what always
what's going to excite me is i've been
doing duality i would rather do that
more because of the chase of storm
chaser because of the the weapons in
there i'm not saying parasite is garbage
but no one came out me like yo cog you
gotta get parasite like that's how you
get my tagging on twitter man every time
i get something so you can just go up
there and go get it
i think that's what it is it's more like
do i need to drop a freestyle about the
weapon and you just go out and go grab
it
oh
i got the hardest shadows the third week
i think as i solo that's when i went in
and did the solo glee on the duality oh
bro you know what i'm doing that's what
i'm doing folks
rng refuses to give me callous mini tool
with incandescent so i've been sitting
there grind i finally got the fifth
joint whatever
yeah and now now but here's the thing
there's something about the the crafting
bro i gotta play with this same loadout
for so long just to level this gun up
just so i can get to the per
it's so much busy work just to get the
load on i want to play with
yeah while you're getting those kills do
an exotic quest it's actually there's
enemies in those quests too that you
have to shoot with any gun it lets you
do whatever gun you want money right now
you're funny
yeah you know yeah oh you gotta level up
weapons what's something in my backlog i
need to do oh let me put on red box
weapons hopefully there was an activity
where i could kill things the damn
frames that i needed so stop it you know
that being at rng sometimes you know how
it go
whatever weapons come to me because
nothing matters i mean whatever
what is destiny really i need the best
perks whatever you know
live and let live what do we what are we
fighting about i don't need that man i
need the magnitions i need that scorch i
need that part of the bill bro
i just love that there's such different
types of what do you think of that
thanos snap baby oh my lord that's my
baby right there bro start off i fire
protocol
get the snaps on deck diffusion grenades
i'm not even killing balls sometimes but
heavy i'm killing them with fusions and
i'm running empowering refs standing in
there shooting heavy oh by the way um
air apparent it's got to we we got to
really talk about it we got to really
talk about every parent right now i
don't know if y'all haven't been using
it but era parent right now
i'm giving up secrets oh man it's bad
again that's the machine joint that we
got from guardian games that gives you
the shield and it um
the the the game
i know you ain't just i know what you're
talking about i know you're right that
one air apparently see what you're doing
to these bosses and get holler back i'm
telling y'all people sleeping on air
apparently i love the fact that you you
have that that mindset towards that
though because
uh you're using different weapons you're
you're built different you use different
lights that's the best part about
destiny is not using meta and using your
own
weapons
to enjoy yourself so i i believe that
that is the he uses the cheese meta
telesto's the only weapon he uses i hate
that guy don't do do that to me
right now
i actually think it's cool that there's
so many different types of players
because some people like cog will just
spend a lot of time like
learning the meta i i tend to just like
get all my quests done and all the
catalysts and exotics i've got to get
all those and then i and then i log off
and and then uh ebontus just does the
same lost sector like
40 times and records every run and
puts it on youtube it's kind of great
all different players
it's good
i'm just letting him finish all of his
words just seeing where he's going to
stop digging this hole it's fine
we just lost another co-host amaze you
good with a two-man show
on the spot like get
yeah it's actually my goal to get kicked
off of the show i'm i'm i'm i'm liking
my odds i'm really i think it's it's
going well
yeah
i know that no
yeah that's true
you know
lord darius actually has a good point
what the point where you guys should
have kicked me off the show was when i
didn't realize that all the red frames
were craftable
after like a few seasons like i really
did not i did not have an excuse to not
know that but i just i never looked it
up guys
i believe in the system
it still hurts by the way i know
believe me i wish those frames in the
dungeon were craftable because two of
them are and four of them aren't and for
me that's still just but like that's
even like an extra paid dungeon
depending on if you bought it extra and
you're like i can only craft two of
these i just keep getting all these
dungeon weapons but i need the
non-dungeon weapons so i can cr like
what is that sentence even that's so
that's a weird decision that one still
bugs me but
oh one of those things would they give
you a red frame if it's not craftable i
know it is kind of weird you can get a
red frame fatebringer that's been an
issue for the one
um
yeah
okay well on that wonderful bombshell we
have covered a whole bunch of fun topics
amazed it has been an absolute blast
having you on here and without any
surprises um
fantastic energy in the show thank you
very much we got another exclusive track
i just started off we got an exclusive
track um
we have analyzed all the business models
that destiny can possibly have and
broken them all down and we also know
everything we want in the future and we
know how to solve the game perfect we
solved all the worlds of destiny's
problems we did a lot today so that was
amazing
you can build me
for my time solving all of your problems
are we gonna what's your billable rate
it's can't be quite as high as uh as
hogue but you know
my billable rate uh
it's 500 per game that i fix
by myself now when you say game or is
this like
mode within game because you know 500 to
fix bungie that's cheap
yeah i you know i do it for the love of
the game okay okay good
positive positive vibes amazing rubbing
off right there that's what it is travis
am i work am i rubbing off on you
i think so all right
if there was a guy to ever rub off on me
any of their qualities i would want it
to be you because i definitely need some
of this both positivity
coolness i
you know i need some of that maybe it
means i can use i can use a truffle
coolness i could use a truckload of
coolness because that ain't here
oh my god
i need a lot of what you've got is
basically what i'm saying i think a lot
of people want to know the secret juice
man to the hype man i tell people that
you know i've i've i've came up with so
many answers but i really came to the
the true answer it's just unique man i
was just blessed with it uh and i it
took a long time to discover it man my
father taught me this man this is this
just uh it's just
unnatural energy that you don't see in
this world you gotta take it from
professor broman where you say this man
it's just not from earth you know what i
mean and then
being able to experience me in person
meet me hands that and
right the head to head and just see that
man you get beside this guy the energy
is just there and i don't know how it's
i don't know how it's traveling like
that it's just like i don't know uh i
just i consider it it's got to be a
blessing because a lot of people really
want to know what the [ __ ] is juicing
i use that blessing if it's there that's
fantastic and that's all i've been doing
you can see it that's all i do it here
every day man get motivation out to the
world i share this energy every day i
ain't standing with it i can sit here
just keep this energy to myself and do
what i got to do and uh i'm i'm here to
see others win as well man i'm here to
motivate others to do exactly and what i
can do if i can do it you can do it too
type deal you know what i mean like a
lot of people really
let me just drop some knowledge on this
uh that's a lot of podcasts
a lot of people really put themselves in
a situation when you just feel like you
can't get out and no situation
ain't no situation in the world
impossible to get out of man it's
lighter than in the tunnel i've
struggled i know what it feels like to
struggle hell i struggle even on days
that i feel like i'm not struggling but
at the end of the day i'm not here to
let a struggle hold me down or pull my
hand down and tell me i can't do
something that's what you got your
positive influences around the world for
just to keep over there picking you up
gotta pay attention man a lot of people
say that things if you gonna pay
attention to some of the things i've
been through in my life when it comes to
gaming and a lot of people say i won't
amount to it and i managed to just shut
those ones up
there is a way of
a way of the mindset called ignoring
yeah a lot of people tend not to do that
you can do that they can't they don't
mean that they can't do it a lot of
people say i understand
and i'll try but you don't do it it's
the hardest thing by saying telling
somebody you're gonna do it versus are
you really going to do it when i leave
this room are you really going to do
that you really got to pick yourselves
about here man struggles aren't going to
leave you this is how life is operated
struggles pull you further they don't
hold you back they built you struggles
built you that's called built that's how
you built yourself up that struggles
help you build that most famous
celebrities in the world when exactly
what you went through jay-z another one
of them big guy at the top he changed
his life around struggles
changed his life made different moves
went up
nipsey hustle
some of your favorite famous video
players some of your famous streamers
some of you
everybody has struggled you can't sit
here and say that things are impossible
to do man if that's impossible to do
you're hanging with the wrong crowd
i don't think you get no better than
that
the boy didn't drop the sermon on us
he just blessed us yes
and cooled us off with a uh
inspirational speech
yeah that's pretty dope shout out to the
legendary maze go ahead i'm sorry i'd
say
on that complete full circle of a
podcast way to bring it back to
back to earth they're amazed but uh i
want to say thank you first off for
coming on it's been a while since we had
you on but
it's an absolute blast having you here
we always enjoy it and it's like you
come on it's just takes all of us to
another level you are your energy is
infectious and if you can't tell it from
the show please make sure go tune into
this man every time you
like a show on earth you ain't gonna get
nothing like it if you're not bop to the
vibes
jamming out with you know everything
that he's doing and just having a good
time while he'll hitch headshots like
mid bars i don't i don't know what to
tell you like go go in there have fun
you will not regret it i love you
i really gotta love you man because uh i
say it every time man that i don't know
i don't know who's doing that you know
what i mean but that at the end of the
day that's just called built but you go
we can go back all those episodes like
we can go back all those episodes ago i
didn't achieve that back in the day you
know what i mean
but i felt that i felt another unique
it's the human body is so amazing man
you're going here and it developed
and you you sit here and say what people
say is impossible and you make it
possible
you know what i mean oh man you make it
possible
being able to freestyle and play a
top-tier level
holy crap
who knew that was gonna be a thing who
knew that i was going to be able to do i
just changed gaming in a whole nother
way up to like 60 70 of those things
i've seen now clips are more yeah
that's that's probably about in 100 200
250. that's crazy i lost track a while
ago i just i saw the numbers just
climbing up so it's just yeah go go
follow him everywhere can't say it
enough but where do they follow you the
floor is yours where do they find the
vibes man
uh ladies and gentlemen everybody out
there the last word podcast first off
thank you all so much for coming out
here y'all can really truly find me on
social media platforms almost all of
them from snapchat the instagram they
all are amazed twitter i'm all over the
place tick tock it's uhm two ways 2yz
catch me live seven days a week man
foundation bungee foundation coming up
this weekend man i'll be dropping
freestyles for the kids the children
love the kids i have never participated
in too many of these events but uh i did
make a promise man as one of the
promises i made to my father that i lost
to cancer that i would definitely do as
much as i can to get back to help the
kids fight cancer and that's my main
mission here is to make sure that we
look out for the kids and the power
level that i would do
for the kids
is out this world i i don't care how
much energy is wasted for it i'm here to
do it for the kids you want vibes you
want energy you want to chat or you want
to chill out you want to bow by with us
come over here and stop by the the home
of vibes twitch.tv slash amazing bonte
comes he comes bunches comes from
most likely every time i see him come
through there man there's always a vibe
so it's just it's it's it's a blessing
please come on stop by i do have youtube
we're working on that um i drop
freestyles constantly so if you need
motivation in the morning you can get it
from instagram if you don't like twitter
you can go over to twitter and get it if
you don't like twitter i got it on
instagram either way you can't get away
from it i'm here to motivate y'all each
and every morning man we're team and i
look at everybody as a team i don't look
at you as enemies i see enemies i brush
them off it's either me against the
world tupac i come up off off that oh
that is me so
i'm i'm starting to understand tupac a
whole lot more versus what i was as a
kid uh
it's just me against the world kind of
deal y'all are starting to see a lot of
that we feel a lot of hate we it's don't
be afraid to be yourselves right that's
right come vibe out with us don't be
afraid to come over there and chat it up
with us a lot of people like to look in
the background just come back come back
goodbye what if i want to just look
don't chill in the cut
hey if you want something to cut we got
the music i don't bother i respect it
salute to the legendary amazed the
legend
i love you to death man i love you
brother love you too brother we always
gotta support people in the community
like you unique you bring tremendous
energy no one does what you do
everything is a vibe and um meeting you
in person you you realize it you don't
say even more so the energy is just as
authentic as it is from behind the
camera salute continuing your journey
we're super proud of you always a
pleasure to have you at the campfire
talking that talk we got exclusive i'm
happy i'm a happy man so i'm good to go
but as far as um what's going on with
the crew you know starters uh talk to a
trash bag what you got going on you know
with yourself what should we looking
forward to what you got popping
yeah uh thanks again amaze amazing to
have you here uh awesome talking with
you you know i saw you at the gcx but i
think you were in the middle of
something oh right yeah you're hosting
the event that's right
[Laughter]
i like it um anyway uh yeah so you can
find me uh you can read my my stuff on
ign.com i've got a preview of xenoblade
chronicles 3 that went live this morning
i've got the review going live later
this month a preview for
um roller drum later this month next
week i think and uh yeah other than that
you can um
watch me on sunday mornings on a show
called bitcast that i do with industry
vet ains the uh attorney at lar
and uh the uh the before photo
uh living before photo um and so uh yeah
you can do that and you can also find me
on twitter at ty got travis
this man out here playing vr he is ever
no i'm just kidding it's all yours
i appreciate it man thank you brother oh
again salute to amaze first and again
for pulling up always a good time for me
you know at lord cognito every sunday is
the lord's day 1 pm eastern the lords
will come back we missed a week a good
little break but now we get come back to
talk to y'all talk about what's going on
in the industry king david lord attic
lord solve the crew
i can't wait to to be with my brothers
again salute to defining duke mr maddie
plays great episode we just put that up
on the patreon right now talking about
game pass what's going on there and of
course if you're interested in uh some
some good you know up-and-coming writers
check out that lords of gaming.net man
we got some fresh talent we're trying to
give people opportunities to be media in
the games industry
and uh i just recorded something really
cool with my boy ty who both of you guys
met at um gcx and we just did a little
pre-destiny talking about season in the
hunted or the lord's minute that'll be
up and uh yeah this is a little company
i deal with so for you people that like
vr you know um we definitely was part of
a program to help remove the barrier for
a facebook
account requirement for uh the quest the
oculus quest so right now it is um the
announcement was official today i'm
proud of that because i was uh working
extensively on that project august is
most likely when the restriction will go
so those who had trepidation who don't
want to associate they lower cognito or
they gov you know they gaming persona
with their facebook persona you can
separate that you can have it a clean
slate there so that will be coming soon
and we got more projects for those
interested in vr so check that out and
uh yeah that's pretty much it for me e
what is going on with you sir finally
settling back in between family visits
and got birthday weekend coming up so my
wife's was yesterday
and then mine is on monday so we're 360
days apart
i will be
one year older one more lap around the
sun coming up on 30 now how old is that
for you 39
oh
big fall oh coming we got yourself
next here is the scary one but
not really technically
technically you're going to be in your
40th year right you shut up no you shut
up
[Laughter]
when i when i complete that 40th lap
around the sun that's when that four
goes on there until then 39.
hold it on trap you hold it
right that's kind of the idea when
you're that close respected
um massive massive thank you to amaze
for coming on
um
appreciate you as always love the
exclusive the energy the discussion was
excellent
um so thank you again for taking the
time out of your schedule because every
minute you're with us i know it could be
somewhere else so believe me we
appreciate it thank you you're taking a
couple hours out of this long anytime
man i'm gonna make sure i get up on this
no matter how far i go man y'all make
sure y'all come back and get me up in
here oh i love y'all to death man uh
love and that's just on that's just on
anything man i will i will cancel
whatever big things or big deals or
something
hey i was gonna say you go to the budget
he's going to come back with the bag and
be like hey guys you want to see this
bag it's a big bag
i want you on the destiny soundtrack
that's my goal for you that's my short
term okay i'm more comfortable for you
yeah amaze
uh doing dropping bars over one of our
little likes animated cinematics please
that would be fantastic you get a drop
oh
you guys know me i am trying to finish
up trying to finish up tunic and i'm
trying to finish up neon white offline
um god of war we actually have a date so
you guys know you'll be seeing that on
the stream in november
i was pleasantly surprised honestly
because i was like delayed delayed
delayed hadn't seen anything delayed
then bam just date with a blog post
which was a little weird i've got good
news for you ebontus
just because it has a release date
doesn't mean anything exactly
yeah
we have now seen games get delayed after
they have gone gold yeah that was which
thing is
unbelievable so yeah
but yes again amazing podcast chat you
guys have been fantastic this evening
thank you guys um if you know of anybody
who enjoys destiny or just wants to hear
a whole bunch of guys talk about a game
that we just have a good time talking
about
film to find the show on video on audio
on either
platform that they find it on if they
drop a like and they enjoy the show let
us know uh but for this episode number
205 with our amazing guest amaze my two
co-hosts ty guy travis lord cognito and
myself ibantis it has been
the
last word